יאללה צא בעצ בוא נשמע אותך רק
תעשה מחיית כפיים
ק שם
אור הדרי ממפי רובאית גדוד שקד
אתה יכול להגדיל טיפה רגע חכה רגע בוא
נראה מה דבר אותו
מדבר מדבר
אני שומע אני רואה שהוא כן קלכן אתה לא
שומע
שניה
אתה לא שומע אותו מדבר
מדבר אחי אורדרי
אור הדרי ממפי רובעית בגדוד שקד
אני בתפקיד כבר שנה א בעצם תחילת התמרון
תופס אותנו במוצב צבעוני תפסנו שמה הגנה א
מוצב צבעוני מוצב ציפורן היה תחת הפלוגה א
תחילת מבצע שהאגה תערי גרופי הגליל היינו
תקופה מרקבה בכפר חולה בגרופי הגליל
ועוד שבוע של כניסה למיסל ג'בל ואז בעצם
נגמר התקופה הזאת של אגרופי הגליל ולפני
התמרון וחזרנו חזרה לגדוד נגמרה בעצם
תקופת התפ והתחלנו נועל קרב לבנג'בל של
והתחלנו בעצם את הנועל קרב לבינג'בל
א בבינג'בל בעצם הפלוגה א נכנסה קודם כל
לאיינטה
בעיין עסקנו בגדול בתיור המרחב א
השמדת תשתיות סריקת איתורים השמדת אויב
וככה התחלנו להתקדם אל עבר בינג'בל שהיא
בעצם היה יד ההתקפה המרכזית של ה של אותו
סבב א מאינתה התחלנו לרדת לכיוון רכס
המחיצה שכונת אל תחריר א שכונה שהפלוגה
פרקה שמה מערב מאוד מאוד משמעותי עם
מכונית טופת א ומצלמה שבעצם צופה את אותו
מרחב א היה שם אחדות של הממם
עלינו למעלה בעצם לעשות תצפית מפקדים. הוא
זיה איזה משהו מנצנץ בתוך חלון של שירותים
של רב קומות, הממם שיירחים, ממם חוד של
הפלוגה, מחלקה אחת. והוא בעצם מזהה את
המצלמה הזאתי, מצלמת ptz מסיבית גדולה. א
אנחנו באותו רגע משמידים את המצלמה מרחוק
א ומתחילים לשאול את עצמנו לאן המצלמה
צופה. הבנו שהיא צופה לכיוון
לכיוון עצי רוקי
אבל לא לא בדיוק הבנו מה מה היא מנסה
לראות ואם זה הצומת או משהו אחר בדיעבד
הבנו שזה הרכב טופת ובמהלך הסריקות שלנו
בבית ספר למלאכה היה שם כמו בית ספר כזה
למכונאות ולמסגרות
אה אנחנו מזהים רכב שנראה קצת חשוד אה
בתוך הרכב א שתי חביות כחולות מלאות בחומר
נפץ ואנחנו בעצם משמידים את הרכב הזה
מרחוק עם פגז של טנק פיצוץ מאוד מאוד גדול
א ואנחנו מבינים שבעצם זה מערב שהיה אמור
א היה אמור להיות מופעל עלינו א ובאמתגו
במיקרופון יש סרטון שלך
יש סרטון יש סרטון של זה מתועד יש גם
סרטון של האבותה א נכנס לתוך הרכב ורואה
את כל החבלה שנמצאת שמה א וזה ככה אירוע
מאוד משמעותי ב
ב בכניסה שלנו שם בהתקדמות לכיוון הקסבה
של בינג'בל א כן צריך להגיד א שגם היה עוד
הרבה דברים לפני זה מצאנו עוד המון אמלך
ואבל אני רוצה להתמקד בדברים הבאמת השונים
והמיוחדים
א משם בעצם התחלנו להגיע התחלנו אה א
לגלוש לכיוון הקסבה והגענו בעצם א ל א
לשכונה האחרונה א לפני הירידה לקסבה עצמה
ממש המורדות לכיוון הקסבה זה כבר בינג'בל
א מה שנקרא
א מובק כן בינג'בל בינ'בל א שמה אנחנו
מוצאים א גם א שני בתים שמחוברים ביניהם
באיזשהו פיר המון המון אמלך א ואז קורה
האירוע בפלחוד עם השני מחבלים שבעצם א
מתקילים שם את הכוח על הפתח נפצע שמה ממם
של הפלחוד א כן, עם האצבע.
ובעצם אנחנו מבינים שהשני מחבלים האלה
ברחו והם ככל הנראה נשארו בפוליגון א
בפוליגון שהבנו שתיחמנו אותו ואנחנו
מבינים שהמחבלים ככל נראה לא יצאו משם כי
מאותו רגע א שמרנו על חוזי על איסוף כל
הזמן מעל השטח הזה והבנו שהם לא ברחו
מהפוליגון שתחמנו
והפלוגה בעצם הפלוגה בעצם מקבלת משימה א
למצוא את המחבלים האלה ולהשמיד אותם
שעול זור זה האירוע שצילמנו באונליין
א אנחנו עושים נועל קרב א גדודי נועל קרב
פלוגתי ואנחנו יוצאים למשימה א ובעצם
עושים א סיר לחץ בשפה הצבאית עושים סיר
לחץ סוגרים את הפוליגון מכל הכיוונים
אנחנו נמצאים בצד אחד צד שני נמצאת פלוגת
השריון
של אמית וודאות הוא נמצא שמה
א והפלחות נמצאים בצד השני ממולנו בסטריפ
המקביל ואנחנו בעצם מבצאים מסגר על כל
הפוליגון כשהמשימה של הפלוגה זה אחרי
המסגר להתחיל בעצם לקלף את האיתורים לקלף
במרכאות לשבור את האיתורים עם באגר א
ולחסוף את המחבלים להרוג אותם א אחרי
שלושה או ארבעה יתורים שהבאגר עובד
והדינין מפלס לו את הדרך
א מני נמצא למטה ליד בבגר יש לי עוד מחלקה
שעלתה לתפוס גובה כדי שנוכל לראות יותר
טוב עם רחפן באוויר ועוד מחלקה שנמצאת
בתוך הנמרים עוד לא פרוקה א והנמרים בעצם
חלק מהמסגר גם בגזרה שלנו אחרי שלוש או
ארבע א שלושה או ארבעה בתים שה
באגר מפרק צרור נורה על הבאגר אני מזהה את
המחבלים מבצע להם יארי ומזהה את הבריחה
שלהם לתוך הבית מעביר את הפקודה קודה בקשר
הגדודי ומתחילים סגירת מעגלים ביחד עם
הרחפנים מבינים לאן המחבלים בורחים א אני
מדבר עם הממם שלי שנמצא למעלה הוא אומר לי
שהוא עם רחפן באוויר והוא מזהה לאן הם
בורחים א ואני אומר לו תקשיב בוא אני נכנס
חזרה למבנה אני מוריד את הרחפן שגם הקשר
שלי היה עם רחפן באוויר אני מוריד אותו א
ובוא נדלג עוד איתור אחד קדימה א המגד
אומר לי רגע לחכות עם הדילוג הזה כדי
שנבין אם אפשר אולי להשמיד אותם עם טנק
ושלא ניכנס לתוך הג
א ובזמן הזה בזמן שאני בתוך האור אני שומע
את הממם שלי אומר שהוא מזהה את המחבלים א
אני לא מספיק להגיד לו איפה אתה מזהה א מה
אתה מזהה ואנחנו שומעים צרור א שפוגע ממש
בחדר שאנחנו נמצאים בו הקשר שלי שהלך
להביא את הרחפן שאמרתי שהורדנו כדי לקחת א
נופל פצוע התחיל לצעוק א לעזרה אומר שהוא
נפצע א ובזמן הזה הירי ממשיך אני מתוך
אינסטינקט שואל אותו איפה המחבלים ברגע
שהוא אומר לי מאיפה ירו עלינו א אני משיב
אש מבלי לראות כל כך את המחבלים ולאן אני
יורה פשוט אש לכיוון שהוא אמר שהם נמצאים
שם א ובזמן הזה אני עוד לא מבין שזה
כוחותינו יורים עליי שזה בעצם הממם בתוך
הנמר עם המקלאן זיהו א אותנו א ועל איך זה
קרה בדיוק אני לא אכנס עכשיו היה שם
איזשהיא תקלה שהם גם היו אלטרמי באור יום
ולא זיהו שאנחנו לוחמי צהל וגם ג' הם
טיפלו מעצור והתבלבלו אחר כך כשהם מחזירו
את הקטלנית א בגדול אבל הם יראו עלינו א
הקשר שלי נפגע אני בזמן הזה לא מבין שזה
דוץ א ואני מחליט לצאת לחלץ את פריינטי
הצעקות שלו היה נשמע לי שהוא לא במצב טוב
ואני גם לא רואה אותו כי הוא נפל מאחורי
איזה חומה אני מחליט לצאת אליו אה א מביא
את הנמר של הפינוי לציר, מפנה אותו ובעצם
אנחנו עוד לא מבינים שזה דוץ אז אנחנו
מתחילים למה הוא נפגע
הוא נפגע א מתחת ליד באיזשהו עורק שהוריד
לו א הרבה דם ורסיס בבטן היום הוא בסדר
הוא בשיקום א והוא כבר חזר לרוץ לו מזמן
אז א כן
אוקיי בשלב זה אנחנו עוד לא מבינים שזה
דוץ
אנחנו לא מבינים שזה דוץ עדיין א ואנחנו
מתחילים סריקה בעצם של האיטור שאנחנו
חושבים שממנו המחבלים ירו תוך חשוב להגיד
למה ירדתי כי הפינוי הזה הציל את החיים
בסוף אני לא יודע לאן זה היה מגיע אבל
איבוד אדם החלטה הייתה נכונה אתה מבין מה
תשמע הקשר שלי השני אנחנו חפק אנחנו קשר
ולוחם חפק אחר כך הוא אומר לי למה יצאת
לחלץ אותו כאילו הוא אמר לי כשיצאת לחלץ
אותו עוד לא ידעת שזה עדוץ אז אמרתי לו
נכון אז הוא שאל אותי למה עשית את זה
עכשיו אני שאלתי את עצמי אם זה אחראי לסכן
את החיים שלי ברמה הזאתי כדי לחלץ אותו או
ששנייה להבין איפה המחבלים אבל מה שהוא
אמר לי שהשבתי באש אני לא שומע שממשיכים
לראות עליי מהרגע שהממם אמר לי שהוא א
שהוא חודל את הירי ועוד לא הבנתי שזה דוץ
אבל כבר היה לי תחושה שאולי והרגשתי די
בטוח לצאת החוצה גם בגלל הנמרים שהיו שם
וגם בגלל זה בשביל לפנות אותו וגם צריך
להגיד הצעקות שלו של הקריאה לעזרה כאילו
אמרתי בואנה אם הוא מת עכשיו אני אני
אתחרט על זה שלא יצאתי אז כאילו יצא יצאתי
ואמרתי אני אני מרגיש שזה הדבר הנכון
לעשות פשוט תחושת בטן ויצאתי א ו אנחנו
מבינים שהמחבלים עוד חיים והממם בזמן הזה
עם הרחפן באוויר הוא הראשון שהבין שזה דוץ
הוא זה שאמר חדל חדל אתם יורים על הדרי א
וזה בתחקיר בדיעבד הבנו א שזה השתלשלות
האירועים
אנחנו ממשיכים בעצם במסגר על המחבלים
מבינים א לאיזה איטור הם נכנסו גם המסייע
שלנו, גם 890 שהיו באבל ובעצם נתנו לנו
קשית אנכית מאוד מאוד טובה, זיהו את
הבריחה של המחבלים. אנחנו מבינים איפה הם
נמצאים. א גם טנקים, גם שני קרדומים של
חיל אוויר שאחד קצת פספס, השני פוגע. א
ומתחילים בעצם לחפש את הBDA בגלל כל
הפגזים והבגר והקרדום וכל אוויר.
נוצר נזק מאוד משמעותי לבית ואם זה לא
הספיק הבאגר שיתח אותו לגמרי והתחלנו לחפש
את הBD ממש רצינו להבין באופן וודאי ששני
המחבלים שאכן א ש שהיינו איתם בהתעקלות הם
אכן נהרגו א ואנחנו במקביל
להוצאה של הריסות של הבית עם הקף של הבאגר
אנחנו גם מתחילים לסרוק את כל הבתים מסביב
כדי באמת לוודא שאנחנו לא מבזבזים את אור
היום שנשאר לנו
א
ובאמת באריסות אנחנו מתחילים מוצאים גופה
ראשונה א ואחרי עוד כמה דקות אנחנו מוצאים
את הגופה השנייה א ופה בעצם טם האירוע הזה
יכול להכניס משפט אחי כל ממ שמה
כן
שומר לכם בקשר אתם לא חוזרים לפני שש א
לפני שאני רואה שני
כן אני אני חושב שזה מה שאירוע כזה זה
אירוע שהוא מה שנקרא
תצוגת תכלית ל למה זה חטיבה גיבעתי ואני
אסביר זה שהיה אירוע הם יתקלות שני מחבלים
והוא הם ברחו יכולנו גם באותו רגע להגיד
טוב אנחנו המשימה שלנו זה בינ'בל א בואו
ניתן לזה איזשהו מענה מקומי ונתקדם א אבל
אני חושב שמה שמאפיין את החטיבה זה
שיוצאים למשימה
ולא חוזרים עד שהיא מבוצעת המשימה הייתה
להביא את השני מחבלים האלה ואחרי ההתקלות
והפצוע והקשר שלי וזה ודוץ והנה הקרדום לו
פה פוגע והפגז היה לו קצת קשה למצוא את ה
ועדיין לא לא חוזרים גם אם יהיה פצועים גם
אם אנחנו עדיין הולכים ועושים את הדבר הזה
וגם אחרי שיצאנו מנקודת הנחה שהמבנה שהם
היו בהושמד עדיין רוצים לראות שבאמת עמדו
במשימה ב100% לא חוזרים עד שלא מבצאים את
המשימה ב-100% ואני זוכר אפילו עם הפציעה
שחזרנו אחרי זה לבית בהגנה חזרנו למוצב
הפלוגתי היה תחושה בפלוגה
מאוד מאוד טובה אפילו עם הפציעה. כן, היה
עצוב להם על פריינטי שהוא נפצע, אבל
התחושה הייתה התחושה של וואו, הלכנו
למשימה למצוא את השני מחבלים ולהרוג אותם
ועשינו את זה. א וזה היה ככה דחיפה מאוד
מאוד משמעותית לפלוגה.
משמה בעצם התחלנו לרדת לכיוון הקסבה ואני
חושב שגם הקסבה זה פרק מאוד חשוב בעשייה
של הפלוגה בלחימה כי השמדנו המון המון
איתורים בתוך הקסבה א גם יכול להיות כי
מחלקת החבלה הגדודית היא אצלי בפלוגה א
וזה בעצם נתן לנו איזשהו אקס פקטור לבוא
ולעשות עוד פעילויות ולהגדיל את התפוקה
ביחד עם 607 וגם המחלקה שלי בעצם לעשות
יותר ולמלקד יותר מבנים
וה מהנקודה הזאתי שאתה מגיע לקסבה ואתה
דורך בתוך הקסבה של בינג'בל לי mפ זה היה
משהו ש אתה כאילו רואה אותה מרחוק אתה
היינו בעיין אתה אתה רואה את הקסבה של
בינ'בל אתה אומר וואו איזה קסבה ובטח מלא
מחבלים וזה וצפיפות וזה ואז אתה מתקדם
לרכס את המחצה ואתה משמיד אויב ואתה משמיד
את השטויות ואתה אומר אוקיי הנה הקסבה קצת
יותר קרובה ואז ביום הזה שאתה מגיע לקסבה
אתה ליקפ אתה מרגיש כאילו כאילו מצאת את
האפיקומן כאילו קיבלת איזה מתנה
אתה אומר בואנה אני בקסבה של בינ'בל אתה
רואה את כל הארס המטורף את הצירים שפרצנו
שם את המבנים שפירקנו שם ואתה אומר מה
יכול לעצור את החטיבה הזאת מה מה יכול
לעצור את הגדוד הזה מה יעצור את הפלוגה
הזאת הגענו לקרצים שמספרים לנו עליו כבר
20 שנה הגענו אליו ו פירקנו אותו ו
הגענו לק צרעות שמדברים איתנו עליו 20 שנה
כבר עוד מאז שאני ילד ותוך כדי זה
ובינג'בל ונאום קורה הכביש ואז אתה מגיע
לקסבה ואתה פשוט הורס את הקסבה. אתה פשוט
בעל הבית, אתה נוסע, אתה פורק, אתה סורק
את היתורים, אתה משמיד אותם. והיה לי חשוב
מאוד לתוווח את זה גם ללוחמים, כאילו
לעצור איתם אחרי ההתקפה להגיע, חבר'ה, אתם
קולטים מה עשיתם עכשיו? אתם מבינים כאילו
את סדר הגודל שאנחנו נמצאים במאוז של
החסבלה ואנחנו בעלי הבית פה. אנחנו
מסתובבים, יוצאים להתקפות באור יום,
מפוצצים פה מבנים, עושים מה שאנחנו רוצים,
פורצים צעירים, מותחים רשתות, מכנים את
הנמרים, מה שאנחנו רוצים. וזה היה לי חשוב
מאוד שהלוחמים לא יבינו שזה ברור מאליו,
שלא יחשבו עכשיו שאוקי, טוב, עוד התקפה,
עוד זה, לא, שנייה לעצור א ולהסביר להם את
הדבר הגדול הזה. א וזה למה היה לי חשוב
כשיצאנו מבנ'בל לעשות איזשהו מעמד קטן
פלוגתי.
בעצם הבאנו דגל ישראל, דגל של הפלוגה ועל
החורבות של המסגד שנמצא ממול האיתור שרואי
קליין, האיתור והחורשה, יותר נכון, של
האירוע עם רועי קליין ולוחמי גולני
ב-2006, היה לי חשוב דווקא לעצור שם ממש
בסדר תנועה שלנו החוצה.
וזה לא היה קל להתעקש על זה כי היה המון
בלטמים וזה אבל היה לי חשוב 10 דקות רגע
לעמוד להגיד לחבר'ה אתם קולטים את סדר
הגודל של מה שעשיתם פה עשיתם היסטוריה
חטיבת גבעתי עשיתה פה היסטוריה באנו
והשמדנו את הקנן צרעות הכי גדול של חסבלה
בינ'בל זה סמל איפה שנסרה לעמד והתרברורב
וירד על עם ישראל ואמר שאנחנו חלשים יותר
מקורי הכביש באנו והשמדנו שם הכל והיה לי
חשוב לעמוד שם להגיד את המילים האלה אה
להעניף את דגל המדינה,
שדגל הפלוגה גם מתנופף שם, להצדיע, להשאיר
את התקווה. עד עכשיו הנה היה לנו את
העיבוד לפני יומיים. זה עלה מלא מעט
חיילים ולא מעט מפקדים וגם אנשים מהמפלג,
שזה זכור להם כאירוע מאוד מאוד מרגש.
היית איתי באירוע הזה שהכנסת ברחביה?
לא הייתי איתכם, אבל זה היה זה היה שם.
זה זכור כאירוע מאוד מאוד מרגש להשאיר את
התקווה על חורבות של מקום שבו היה לנו קרב
קשה לצבא שלנו א כשמאחורינו העשן מתאמר
מעל בינ'בל זה תמונה זה תמונה מטורפת העשן
מתאמר ב שם בעמק ואנחנו שמה שרים את
התקווה מצדיעים לדגל המדינה כולם על ציוד
כולם מחויכים כולם מסופקים
ויצאנו מהסבב הזה באמת עם הראש בעננים
א משם בעצם מבין המשימה הבאה שהייתה לנו
זה לחזור לעין אתה ובעצם לעשות השמדות כמה
שיותר השמדות זה בעצם יום שאתה קם בו
עושים נועל קרב ויוצאים בעצם לסריקה של
פוליגונים והשמדה שלהם
מה הייתה שיטת העבודה והשמדות
שיטת העבודה זה נועל קרב כל ערב היינו
מתקבצים כל הממים ואני א מול טצה במסך
ומתחילים לדבר רגע על השיטה, איך אנחנו
רואים את השיטה, השלבים, א, שיטת הפינוי
ושפה משותפת. א בגלל שהעבודה היא נהיתה כל
כך שיטתית ואתה לפעמים בפעילות אחת של
השמדה, יצאנו גם להשמיד 25 איתורים במכה
אחת. א אז אתה חייב שפה משותפת, כי ברגע
שאתה מדבר במספרי היתורים נורא קשה א
והשפה המשותפת עשתה לנו מאוד סדר, זה נהיה
מין בדיחה כזאת בגדוד, השפה המשותפת של
הפלוגה, כי היינו נותנים כל מיני שמות
מצחיקים ליתורים, אבל זה היה עובד. זה היה
עובד והיינו משתפים את זה גם עם הפלוגת
הנדסה ובאמת הצלחנו ככה לעבוד בצורה מאוד
מאוד שיטתית ויסודית והפלוגה באותו סבב
סרקה בקצב של מעל 20 יתורים ביום בממוצע א
זה היה מאוד משמעותי בעצם אני זוכר את
לוריה אומר לי אתה תהיה חתום על ההשמדה של
האצבע החמישית שלינתה אני זוכר את המשפט
הזה שהוא אומר לי ואמרתי זה פתאום עשה לי
כזה קליק שכאילו בואנה אני צריך לתווך את
זה לחיילים
כאילו אני הוא אמר לי את זה וזה עשה לי
כזה אני אהיה חתום על זה אני אהיה הממפי
שעוד לא יודע מה כמה שנים אני אספר
לחיילים שלי כשאני מגד או אני אספר לילדים
שלי ולנחדים שלי אני השמדתי את ה אנחנו
השמדנו את הקסבה של בינ'בל והיה לי חשוב
שגם החיילים ירגישו את התחושה הזאת א וכך
באמת היה כל הסבב זה היה תחילת הפיק
של הרחפנים ממש סוף הסבב של א של עין היית
הפיק הזה שהם הבינו שזה עובד ד חסבלה ושזה
עמלך יעיל ואז בעצם נגמר הסבב יצאנו
והמשימה הבאה שלנו הייתה עליתני א בעצם כן
Ja.